aux etats-unis à l'âge de 2 ans en
moyenne un enfant et trois heures par
jour devant un écran en france à l'âge
d'un an un enfant à une heure par jour
confrontés à un écran
bon évidemment je veux culpabiliser
personnes il est hors de question de
dire vous êtes un mauvais parent parce
que vous mettez vos enfants devant des
écrans je le fais moi-même tous mes
proches le fond et c'est ce que l'on
sait juste est ce qu'il est important de
savoir c'est que c'est mauvais pour son
enfant faut donc le savoir
à partir du moment où on le sait chacun
fait comme il peut chacun fait comme il
veut
faut juste savoir que c'est une question
santé publique trop d'écran avec les
enfants avec les tout-petits
c'est très mauvais pour eux alors ce qui
a été prouvé par des études c'est que
les enfants qui sont confrontés beaucoup
à des écrans notamment le matin avant
d'aller à l'école avant dallas la crèche
ils ont trois fois plus de risques
d'avoir des troubles du langage très
concrètement ils vont beaucoup moins
bien parler que les autres au cp quand
les enfants entrent au cp
normalement un enfant doit connaître
entre 2500 et 3000 mots de vocabulaire
ce qui est à peu près la base un niveau
normal qui lui permet d'échanger les
enfants qui regardent beaucoup d'écrans
certains sont à 3 à 400 mots de
vocabulaire 3 400 mots de vocabulaire
sais rien mais quand d'aimer ça entre
des pédiatres vous faire défaire des
petits dessins des enfants qui ont deux
ans deux ans et demi trois ans et bien
trois ans à faire un beau petit bonhomme
quand on n'est pas trop exposer aux
écrans parce qu'on a l'habitude
d'observer la vie en 3d autour de soi
etc
donc on va faire une belle petite est un
beau petit vente des beaux petits pieds
et des belles petites viande
l'enfant qui va regarder pendant 2h 3h
4h par jour des écrans son petit
bonhomme il va ressembler à rien du tout
ça peut paraître tout bête on se dit au
final j'ai pas envie d'en faire un
dessinateur de mon enfant mais si ça
illustre que son cerveau n'a pas évolué
comme il faudrait et si vous imaginez si
on commence déjà à l'âge de trois ans
avec un retard qu est-ce que ce sera
plus tard ce que la science a également
prouvé c'est que ça peut avoir des
conséquences sur la motricité
parce que des enfants qui vont regarder
quatre heures par jour des écrans à
l'âge de deux ans ça arrive on a
beaucoup plus qu'on pourrait le penser
bah sont des enfants qui vont un peu
moins joué dans leurs champs de courir
sauter allez dehors aller au parc etc
pour la sociabilité aussi là aussi c'est
prouvé que les enfants qui vont regarder
pendant quatre heures même cinq heures
même six heures par jour
des écrans de simplement ils ont moins
de copains ils ont un copain parce
qu'ils passent moins de temps dehors ils
passent moins de temps avec d'autres
enfants
et puis aussi parce que quand on a
regardé autant les écrans là aussi c'est
prouvé on est vénère les enfants ça a un
impact sur leur cerveau et ils sont
moins enclins à s'ouvrir aux autres
dans le partage est dans les changes une
autre chose qui a été prouvé c'est que
les enfants qui ont des problèmes de
sommeil qui ont des troubles du sommeil
et dieu sait si on a beaucoup surtout
les petits eh bien il ya un lien souvent
avec les écrans c'est à dire qu'il ya
une courbe qui montre que plus un enfant
va être exposé à un écran durant la
journée moins bien il va dormir c'est
d'ailleurs comme nous adultes
on sait que si on est beaucoup sur notre
téléphone avant de dormir on va moins
bien dormir d'un enfant c'est encore
plus le cas si votre enfant peu importe
son âge d'ailleurs dort mal essayé de
retirer ou de moins de diminuer son
exposition aux écrans et la science vous
prouve que en théorie devrait mieux
dormir assez rapidement je suis père de
trois enfants donc évident moi aussi la
tentation quand je prends le train quand
je fais des longs trajets en voiture
voir le week-end quand je reçois des
copains à la maison c'était de mettre
des hommes et enfants devant des écrans
pour être peinard comme tout le monde
pendant deux heures effectivement ça
marche bien les écrans sauf qu'avec ma
femme ça nous pose des problèmes donc on
s'est dit ce qu'on a à faire c'est qu'on
va lire on va sans registre et avec
notre dictaphone lisant des histoires
qui existe j soit reconnue ou pas connus
en inventer et nous mêmes les
enregistrer on les passera à nos enfants
et on a commencé à les faire écouter à
nos enfants faisait des petits montages
on était une petite musique et on a vu
que ça marchait bien sûr nos enfants du
cours les a donnés à nos frères et nos
soeurs nos copains etc et tous nous et
ça que ça marche bien c'est les captives
nos enfants mais ils sont pas confrontés
à un écran
il écoute ça stimule leur imagination
d'un an nous en parlent ça ouvre des
débats etc
du coup on célibat temps pourquoi pas en
faire profiter le plus grand nombre du
coup on a négocié avec des éditeurs le
droit d'enregistrer leur histoire en
podcast ça s'appelle encore une histoire
c'est destiné aux enfants à partir de 2
ans et demi trois ans est évidemment
gratuit et l'idée est de proposer des
alternatives pour occuper nos enfants
stimuler leur imagination sans les
mettre devant des écrans et franchement
c'est magnifique notamment en voiture on
reçoit beaucoup de messages de parents
qui nous dit vous avez sauvé notre âge
et parce que pendant les quatre heures
ou 5 heures de route qu'on a passé on a
écouté vos podcasts
on a écouté on a écouté vos podcasts en
boucle nos enfants était calme
tranquille on voyait dans leurs yeux les
bulles d'imagination donc provoquer
l'écoutent de ces histoires et c'est
vrai qu'en arrivant à la fin du trajet
l'enfant n'est pas sûr excité comme
après 5h d'écran ou et qu'ils aient les
yeux rouges et c'est là c'est un peu
l'inversé donc foncer vers les histoires
que ce soit avec ses podcasts avec les
histoires que vous faites vous même que
vous enregistrez vous même c'est tout
simple à faire
être le ca change tout est néanmoins
vous passez un trajet tranquille vous
pouvez discuter
le papa et la maman dans la voiture